Jeff Bezos chief executive for nearly 30
years of amazon.com ever heard of it is
stepping down well first public company
to lose one trillion dollars in market
value the company's market cap of 878
million
it's possible I'm not going to like pop
the table on this but I do think it's
possible that he returns to help me
study the show
[Applause]
Amazon has become the world's first
company to lose one trillion dollars
worth of market value dropping from 1.88
trillion down to 879 billion this isn't
just some sort of Market overreaction
either as Amazon's fundamentals aren't
looking much better in fact Amazon's
trillion 12 month profit has plunged
from over 30 billion down to even
negative numbers as such they've been
cutting jobs like crazy having laid off
27 000 people within the past several
months itself and all of this has
unfolded within just two years of Jeff
Bezos retiring from his position as CEO
this has led to many investors feeling
that it was a Bezos that was the secret
sauce to Amazon's success sparking
rumors that Bezos will return to the
helm to turn around the company one
investor named Michael batnick has even
gone as far as predicting that Bezos
will return by the end of 2023 this
might sound unprecedented but that's not
actually the case in fact it's pretty
common versus Yost return if things
aren't going great Michael Dell for
example retired back in 2004 but as Dell
started struggling as we headed into the
financial crisis Michael got back to
work more recently Bob Iger retired in
2020 after serving as Disney CEO for 15
years but after Disney's Dog fell 50
then Disney plus became a money pit I
could return to his position in late
2022 likely the best example of a CEO
returning though is Howard Schultz who
just can't seem to get a break from
Starbucks every time he leaves the
company the stock goes into the toilet
so he basically just comes back on an
ass needed basis having served three
different terms so far so the idea of
Bezos returning is not that far-fetched
and considering the current position of
Amazon it's well warranted too so join
me as we look into whether Jeff Bezos
will actually make a grand re-entrance
and what exactly that could mean for the
future of Amazon
foreign
starting off with the case for Bezos the
first thing we have to consider is
whether Bezos is even in a position to
return and the answer is absolutely for
one he's not even 60 years old yet
meaning that he has plenty of working
years left shoulder were closer to 70
when they returned to their respective
companies also it's not like he's gotten
super involved in some sort of other
effort yes he has been focusing on Blue
origin his rocket company but it's not
like that's a new Endeavor people often
like to mock Bezos for copying Elon Musk
and SpaceX and in some aspects he
definitely has but blue origin has
actually been around since 2000 so most
of its growth was achieved without Bezos
being directly involved in fact Bezos
isn't even the CEO of blue origin it's
actually some guy named Bob Smith also
the only reason blue origin is even
possible is because of Bezos Wilt from
Amazon so if Bezos wants to give blue
origin the best chance of success it
would make sense that act as Amazon
Fortune which brings us into the
incentive argument the bottom line is
that there is no one in the entire world
that's as incentivized to turn around
Amazon as Bezos Amazon's current CEO
Andy Jazzy owns about a quarter billion
dollars worth of Amazon stock meanwhile
Bezos still owns about 123 billion
dollars worth of Amazon stock so
theoretically speaking Bezos should be
500 times as financially incentivized as
a jazzy to turn around Amazon but I
would argue that his motivation goes
much deeper than just financial gain for
Bezos this is the company he founded way
back in 1994 that he spent virtually his
entire adult life building so it's safe
to say that Bezos wouldn't just sit on
the sidelines and watches Empire crumble
especially if he could do something in
fact he's probably the best person to do
something because he's already handled a
far worse situation back in the early
2000s during the.com Crash Amazon stock
straight up fell 95 and at the time
Amazon was still very much a startup
during a time where virtually all other
internet startups were collapsing this
meant that it was extremely hard to
raise money recruit talent and gather
the resources needed for a turnaround
but Bezos was able to do it he
Diversified the business and launched
AWS and the rest is history today Amazon
is indeed doing bad but they're still
one of the biggest corporations on the
planet with 64 billion dollars in the
bank so if Bezos was able to turn around
the 2000 Amazon he has a pretty good
shot at turning around the 2023 Amazon
but the truth is that a lot of bases
impact on Amazon wouldn't even be
strictly strategic this isn't to say
that Bezos wouldn't make a great
strategic decisions but I would argue
that his bigger role at Amazon would
actually just be his presence itself the
reality is that there's only so much
that a single person can do but that
single person Spirit and the morale can
accomplish infinitely more now I know
that the general public and the media
aren't exactly the biggest fans of Bezos
most people just him as the bald slave
driver but this isn't the case with Wall
Street or Amazon's corporate employees
sure they may not like him either but I
can assure you that they think that he's
effective as hell I mean just look at
this this is Amazon under Bezos
leadership and this is Amazon under
Jazzy's leadership if you were a
corporate Amazon employee and most of
your compensation depended on stock comp
and the growth who would you rather have
lead the company I'm gonna guess Bezos
and that this is especially true for
leadership whose entire compensation is
basically stock as such Bezos simply
returning could be the morale boost that
investors and executive leadership need
to get back on track if you're not a fan
of Bezos returning though don't worry as
there is a pretty strong case for him
not returning as well
foreign
for starters the case against the Bezos
returning begins with the fact that he
never really left in the first place
sure he gave up his position as CEO but
he simply switched to being executive
chairman it's not like Bill Gates who
has completely left Microsoft something
else to note is that even as CEO Bezos
was serving in more of a German type of
capacity he was never really in the
weeds of operations like Elon or
something Bezos strongly felt that as a
senior executive his job was to make a
small number of super high quality
decisions in fact he didn't even start
work till 10 AM and his job each day was
to just make three good decisions now
I'm not here to argue the effectiveness
of this type of role but what I can say
is that it's not a particularly time
intensive mentally intensive sure but
not time intensive so it doesn't really
require Bezos to take on the CEO role
again he can just make his three
decisions a day as executive chairman
and speaking of decisions Bezos strongly
believes in making decisions that play
out over the long term in fact when
friends congratulate him for a good
quarter he tells them thank you but that
quarter was baked three years ago so
according to Bezos himself a CEO's
decisions can't be judged until three
years later newsflash Jazzy has barely
been CEO for two years so according to
Bezos own logic none of this is Jazzy's
fault all of it is actually Bezos fault
as the decisions that led to Amazon's
current situation were actually made in
2019 and 2020 when Bezos was CEO so
while it may seem like Jazzy taking over
is what screwed up Amazon the real
culprit was actually Bezos last
decisions before he retired so by that
logic it makes no sense for Bezos to
take over once again as this was all his
fault also Jazzy hasn't had enough time
to really be judged as a CEO yet so it's
not really fair to replace him just yet
the reality is that Jazzy is actually
super qualified to be CEO I mean that's
why he was picked for the job in the
first place he joined the company way
back in 1997 before the.com bust so he
was also very much involved in
amazon's.com turnaround in fact you
could argue that Jazzy was the architect
of Amazon's turnaround Bezos original
idea to turn around the company was to
actually launch something called
merchant.com the service was supposed to
help other retailers set up their own
e-commerce platforms similar to Shopify
but this turned out to be a massive
failure and that's why Bezos allowed
Jazzy to start up AWS or the cloud side
of Amazon and ever since then AWS has
been the lifeblood of Amazon in fact
it's the only reason that the retail
business was even viable as AWS was able
to pay for all the losses and upfront
Investments this is true even today as
Amazon's retail business is still
teetering between profitability and
unprofitability so really it was the
Jazzy that turned around Amazon back in
the 2000s so from that perspective it
actually makes more sense to give Jazzy
a shot than Bezos a shot it would also
play out much better on the media which
brings us into our next point which is
that the Bezos is a PR Nightmare and
it's no secret that the media hates
Bezos and there are plenty of good
reasons to hold a grudge against the guy
the reality though is that his
involvement or lack of involvement
doesn't really change any of the bad
attributes of Amazon it's not like the
lives of warehouse and delivery workers
suddenly became magical after Bezos
departure it's also not like Amazon
suddenly stopped avoiding taxes as much
as possible but when Bezos is not
directly involved all of this is just
written off as a big evil Corporation
doing big evil Corporation things when
Bezos is involved however it all of a
sudden becomes personal it's no longer
Amazon that's causing all this damage
it's actually Bezos the world's richest
man that's doing all this he's the
reason he's the one abusing warehouse
workers he is the one evading taxes he's
the physical manifestation of evil rich
dude whether this is accurate or not is
irrelevant when the public has such a
large bias against the dude probably not
the best idea to put him back in the
spotlight as especially as a consumer
business
foreign
there's quite a few reasons going
forward and against the Bezos but what
does Bezos think well he hasn't publicly
talked about the situation but that
doesn't really mean anything this isn't
the type of situation that you plan on I
mean there's a reason that he retired
while Iger for example says that he was
very very surprised by his own return to
Disney so Bezos hasn't exactly dropped
any specific hints but we can dubiously
speculate based on his principles and
overall thoughts while Bezos is likely
disappointed by the current state of
Amazon I don't think he's particularly
surprised in fact he's been anticipating
this moment for his entire career as he
always knew that Amazon's downfall was
inevitable companies have short life
spans Charlie and Amazon will be
disrupted one day and you worry about
that I don't worry about it because I
know it's inevitable companies come and
go and the companies that are the
shiniest and most important of any era
you wait a few decades and they're gone
and your job is to make sure that you
delay that date I'd sure I would love
for it to be after I'm dead
with that in mind Bezos could return to
Amazon but what's the purpose sure he
might be able to turn around the company
and get them to two three five trillion
dollars but what does that accomplish
he'll just be even more hated and it's
not like he would have saved Amazon
completely he would have simply delayed
their Downfall by another 10 or 20 years
but the eventual death of Amazon is
still inevitable so why waste time on
such a vanity metric especially when he
could be working on Rockets or his Earth
font and hopefully actually create
long-term change this is precisely what
Bill Gates did after he left in 2000
Microsoft got destroyed in fact the
stock didn't move for the next 17 years
but Gates didn't come back he actually
stepped back further sold more stock and
focused even more on his foundation and
the given that Bezos has also reduced
his stick down to the single digits I'm
pretty sure that Bezos leans on the side
of not returning but who knows Amazon is
his baby so I'm sure he'll have a tough
time just watching the Carnage from the
sidelines it's not just Amazon that's
facing an existential crisis all of big
Tech is going through a similar turmoil
if you'd like to learn why all
monopolies eventually fail check out
this video but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one